Speaker 1: today, maybe already has happened.
Donald Trump will be arrested and charged
with what we have now learned will be 34 felony
counts.
But an exclusive Yahoo News report by Michael
Isikoff, the chief investigative correspondent,
doing really good work at Yahoo! News, said
there will be no handcuffs and there will
be no mugshot in special treatment for the
failed former president Donald Trump.
This is historic stuff.
We are living through a remarkable event.
Michael Isikoff writes, as the article just
disappeared, donald trump will be placed under
arrest Tuesday and informed he has been charged
with 34 felony counts for falsification of
business records.
According to a source briefed on the procedures.
A New York City police arrest report summarizing
the charges against Trump will be prepared
and entered into the court system.
Trump will be led into the courtroom and formally
formally arraigned on the charges, none of
which are misdemeanors.
Remember, the right wingers were saying these
are all misdemeanors.
All misdemeanors.
Well, maybe there's one felony.
These are reportedly all felonies.
But Trump will be given special treatment.
He will not be put in handcuffs.
He will not be placed in a jail cell.
What a dream that would be.
And he will not be subjected to a mug shot.
Even most white collar defendants are subject
to those three elements.
The Manhattan District Attorney's Office has
been consulting with Secret Service and New
York City court officials said there's no
reason to give him a mug shot.
There's no reason to put him in handcuffs.
The stated reason for handcuffing is defendant
might be a flight risk or a threat to the
D.A. or court personnel.
Neither are judged to be relevant for former
President Trump, given that he will be protected
by Secret Service agents at all times.
At all times.
This is going to be an incredible event, an
incredible event.
We will be live.
We were live again.
The timing of recording today is a little
bit complicated for what is taking place.
There will be still photos in the courtroom.
There will not be video cameras in the courtroom.
And this was another subject of much controversy.
As I said, I can't think of any trial proceedings,
any court proceedings rather more relevant
to the public interest than the arraignment
of a former president for which there should
be cameras, live video cameras.
But there will not be sort of jokingly, do
you think that this proceeding will finally
give us Trump's real height and weight, which
he's been lying about for a long time, claiming
to be six three and to 39?
Probably not.
And that's sort of a joke.
That's not really important.
We are going to now see over the next 24 hours,
and I hope everybody is prepared for it.
We are going to see the worst of the worst
of MAGA Trumpism.
I'm going to make a small adjustment here
to my audio.
We are going to see the absolute worst faith
takes.
This isn't justice.
No, no, no, no, no.
It is justice to learn and realize that even
a former president is not above the law.
These are politically motivated charges.
You haven't even seen the charges and you're
not aware of the evidence.
How could you possibly make that claim at
this time?
This is never done where you use testimony
from a lawyer because it's protected.
Well, what about the crime fraud exception,
which we're going to talk about later?
And by the way, we don't yet know how it worked
out, but Marjorie Taylor GREENE leading a
protest in New York City, quite literally,
as we are recording by tomorrow.
So I'm sure I will have more information for
you about how that turns out.
So we will follow all of it.
We will report on it.
I hope you will join me live.
And in the meantime, Donald Trump's final
24 hours before his arrest indicating that
he is absolutely terrified